yes i mean it's kind of gotten to feel
like december it's our last day of fall
though winter officially arrives
tomorrow morning like right around 8 a.m
so
get ready for a nice day but a cool day
again temperatures were below normal all
weekend great shot as we look out across
downtown las vegas this morning and if
you do have stuff left on your list to
do if you still have gift buying and
errands to run and groceries to buy if
you can fit them in at the beginning of
the week instead of waiting till
christmas eve or the end of the week i
would say do it early because we do have
a chance for rain coming our way later
in the week and mountain snow and maybe
even on christmas weekend of course by
christmas weekend it's too late so get
it done all right we got lots of 30s
around the valley this morning nellis
the coldest spot at 27 along with red
rock at 27. some breezes up there at
kyle canyon boy we've had single digits
up in ely this morning cali any in the
teens 25 in indian springs from below
freezing this morning 42 in laughlin 36
in boulder city look at cedar city at
21. so we showed you pictures earlier of
the canyon lee canyon is open for skiing
so pretty much all the ski resorts
across the west are open for skiing now
and the sierra is going to get dumped on
again with a couple of more systems
coming in models are really divided on
whether this first one is going to
converge or if it's going to split
either way it will bring rain and snow
mostly to california and then eventually
later in the week we'll get a chance for
that as well but you can see the rain
and snow moving into the northwest right
now there is warm air and rain moving up
into east texas louisiana this morning
and will continue to spread around the
gulf coast a little bit of snow around
the great lakes that's really a lot of
cold air over the northern plains the
great lakes even teens i mean 20s down
into little rock this morning nashville
has been in the 20s still below freezing
and look at the 20s raleigh durham d.c
new york and boston have been in the 20s
this morning it is cold in those areas
if you're traveling early for christmas
so we'll start out with sunshine today
then we'll have increasing clouds
keeping light winds not really looking
for wind until later in the week our
first day of winter will actually warm
up a little bit upper 50s close to 60
clouds and sun and then a slight chance
of showers wednesday night as we get the
first taste of that system in the west
and a 40 chance of showers on thursday
with breezy winds too so that's kind of
a messy day on thursday christmas eve a
slight chance of showers left slight and
then another system will bring us a
chance of rain and mountain snow on
saturday and temperatures stay somewhat
mild in the mid to upper 50's low 50's
by monday so